I feel like we called up each other and
we said let's color coordinate we did we
that's right we texted each other and
we're like let's just like you know have
it all worked here it works out it looks
good I can't show as much skin as her
about you know but ever I would be I
know
well congratulations it's like you're
getting used to seeing you guys know the
country red carpets together or a blue
carpet about Paulette yeah it is our
third third red carpet together now our
blue carpet whatever I can see you're
countin I know
but yes I absolutely love having her out
here it makes it so much better for me
and it's already cool yeah and last time
we were talking we were talking about
wedding news
any update here there's there's no
update there's no update but I'm working
on it you are you're not gonna propose
on the carpet tonight are you
I'm not know she she's already warned me
if I ever propose to never do it in a
public said onstage I would rather
public setting yeah he wanted to be
private but you know it's coming huh I
mean I I hope at the end of the day I
feel like we're so happy I'm not
necessarily looking for that next step
to change anything it's just yeah it'll
be an exciting time for sure it'll
definitely happen at some point well let
us know okay all right I will I noticed
you guys checking out the little pug dog
over there you know Laura well we both
love dogs but Lauren really really loves
a dog and we she's begging me for a dog
at this point could be the first step
towards baby I I agree it would be a
great first step but she is obsessed
with corgis for days
every day on Instagram I just sent him
like
settlement is just constantly photos of
us honestly the truth she sends me
photos of corgis every day I think that
would be nice and maybe you could
propose a whit the Corgi
I mean honestly maybe I could that's
actually a great idea
the caller you could wrap with it you
could wrap the ring around the collar
Wow ring around the collar you get it
talking uh without her I gave you some
more ideas
so congratulations you reach like 1
million streams or something like that 1
billion
oh sorry that 1 billion is completely
under estimate right it's a billion you
know my team just brought the plaque out
surprised me I had a show recently and
for me I had no idea but what a great
what a great stepping stone in my career
and and I had no idea I would ever reach
a billion streams that's pretty cool
pretty cool that's a huge thing is going
to Dolly Parton's anniversary of I will
always love you it's coming up you know
the wonderful song I'll always love you
so you guys get to fill in the blank I
will always love you because why
my my is this in response to how I feel
about her exactly not about dolly but if
you want to tell me why you love dolly
you can not only is she beautiful on the
inside but she's beautiful on the
outside and absolutely the funniest
person I've ever met and I love that
that's a lot of fun to be around
she's great to be around you got a feel
on the bike I know I was you gotta took
it from me but I will always love you
because you make me laugh and it's true
always making me laugh that's so
important right for long-lasting very
important I agree I think that's the
number one thing for me is you gotta got
to be able to laugh together
[Music]